a chaotic scene last night in a
henderson neighborhood one person
killed two others injured when a
domestic dispute ends in gunfire this
all happened on hunt field drive
that's near wigwam and green valley
parkways and that is where
sally jaramillo is live for us tonight
with an update sally
david this is a quiet neighborhood
according to people who live here but
last night
it was definitely a different story
police and ambulances and reports of a
shooting
neighbor is also in shock as they didn't
think anyone even lived at the home
where the crime took place
my son indicated he heard you know some
scuffle
and some gunshots it was engulfed in
police this family just moved here from
minneapolis while they didn't want to be
on camera they still can't believe what
happened monday night
our area that we came from was a little
because of some police violence a little
sketchy so it was surprising they're
running down the streets with rifles and
you know guns and you know kicking
indoors and
you know so you're like where did i move
according to henderson police a
37-year-old woman and her 39-year-old
husband got into a fight
while he left the home she called
friends to come help her
the men returned shooting a 48-year-old
woman in the face
and shooting two 21-year-old men in the
torso
they had two gentlemen on on the ground
giving cpr one of them was taken right
away
into an ambulance the second they
continued to work on him and then
eventually stopped cpr and he was
then taken you know via ambulance the
three victims were taken to sunrise
hospital the woman shot in the face did
not make it
the husband identified as andre andrews
was arrested
charged with domestic battery open
murder and attempted murder
thoughts and prayers i mean like i said
however this played out and what bring
it to this i just hope that they
you know find some peace in everything
and can
can come back from it because it was
definitely traumatic
as for the identity of the woman it has
not been released yet reporting live in
henderson sally jaramillo 8 news now
sally thank you